how many days have you been a Muslim for
I said the words and everything when I
went to the mosque I was pretty private
about it for a while as a public figure
whatever you don't want to seem like you
just look what I just did I just want
something like you know it's pretty
private about it and I've been reading
more I think it's been about a month
understanding in Islam that we're all
equal nobody is better than us we are
all just people and and God is the real
Creator the way you say it it's like
we're nothing it kind of gives you makes
me happy in a way where you can let go
of your ego that you don't need to
compete with other people you want to
live the happiest life and you you want
to be able to serve God because he
created everything that we have the
sentiment of the West you say you never
discuss your salary you never discuss
politics you don't talk about religion
on it so what what are you going to talk
about what else is there to talk about
besides money besides God besides what's
going on in the world anything else is a
waste of energy is a waste of your voice
but they tell us that because they want
you to have mindless conversations where
you're just talking about celebrities
you're talking about sports you know who
one talking about other people's
achievements and then you have nothing
here we go
let me call these guys up
about a minute early
foreign
just let me uh let me put on my camera
all right no worries give me a second do
we have all three or just two today just
oh no couldn't make it because he's in
France is like 2AM from uh yeah
understandable
yeah but he does he says and says
salaams in his regards he's very happy
that you're Muslim nicest
congratulations and uh passes to Islam
it's great to to talk to see you guys
again um I saw you did a good podcast
with uh sartorial shooter I really
enjoyed watching that
that was a real pleasure of ours and
it's a pleasure to be talking to you
again alhamdulillah congratulations on
accepting Islam I saw my camera is
loading here it's being a little off
yeah I need to I'm fixing up my stream
too in a second all right perfect so
probably what we're gonna do if you
don't mind uh we're gonna test our
stream to make sure that they can
actually hear the audio on on here and
then we're gonna join
okay
yeah I'm live right now and I'm already
live on Rumble
oh yeah that's cool yeah I had a lot of
debate so far a lot of people I
announced my conversion or reversion to
Islam and people were pretty mixed I
have a lot of Hardcore Christians and
they were I'm surprised about how upset
they were
a lot of them because I don't know it's
like a discounted Warfare but I think
that there's a there's a common enemy
and I don't think that Christians and
Muslims uh should think of themselves as
enemies
yeah 100 actually uh what you're saying
hasmere in the Quran as well Allah he
says come to terms with people of the
book that you worship one God so you're
spot on with that
and they said that I was some people
were happy because they said I was
um doing dawa like right after my
conversion by by promoting it
yeah 100 100 percent
and it's people in the chat are saying
because oh sorry go ahead I'll sell you
on a Pros podcast and you were you were
just straight out bro
so that does that mean I'm gonna go to
heaven
inshallah bro
ultimately bro it's the mercy of Allah
that gets you into Jannah
we'll discuss all this so I want to
learn more what do you think is the best
way because I gotta be honest man I have
um I've been reading
I've been reading texts and watching
videos and people have been sending me
websites to look at in order to
um as a good introduction to Islam
and I I would say I know quite a bit I
have a good conversations the Quran is
really difficult to get through
especially the translation I don't know
if you guys speak Arabic but the English
translation is is rough
which way which translation you're
reading because is it the one that says
like Thy shall not and like yeah yes oh
yeah you're reading the wrong one five
do you have the clear Quran on hand I
don't have it on me bro no worries
nickel we'll send you a good translation
there's one called the clear Quran it's
it's very simple and straight to the
point it's Modern English not that
Shakespearean stuff okay great yeah I I
don't like reading the Shakespeare
language and it was confusing yeah
probably does yeah I get you bro
normally do you hit me through the mic
or through the speakers no it's not good
um yeah
and we're live on uh the three Muslims
as well just quickly
welcome back to the race podcast people
are saying it's muted so let me try and
fix this inshallah in the meantime
I think this is how I do it but yeah
let's continue so I've been wondering um
what or who influenced you to accept
this time I know that you were looking
to Islam beforehand with like Malcolm X
and Dave Chappelle but what do you say
it's fair to say people you know men
like sartorial shooter and other people
because you visited him recently uh had
an influence on you yeah he brought me
to the mosque for the first time that
was my first time there bro the funniest
thing was just how I didn't know that
women don't go to the mosque it was it
was all men were walking out right you
have to wash first off I obviously know
the Subscribe but you wash everything
you wash your face and then we're
walking back out and putting our shoes
back on because you don't walk in with
your shoes and there were just no I'm
like why are the women not here and I
was there with some a pretty high level
person in Dubai and he's just like the
women don't need a they're at home like
they're cooking they don't need to why
do they need to be that women don't need
to be outside I'm just like yeah I had
no idea
yo rummy bro could you make the full
screen on streamer it shows in like the
full view yeah it should be full screen
now let me know because I just went full
screen but yeah that's that's that's
kind of uh that's kind of half the truth
there is definitely Merit to that and
there is a aspect of Islam where women
should be kind of I don't want to say
hidden away but you know kept saying you
know there's a Hadith
all right it's froze
yeah you're there bro yeah my camera
turned off but um you want to finish how
do you feel me
yes bro
give me one quick second my camera looks
so uh
so white for some reason I gotta wipe it
they're both no worries oh okay yep all
right pardon the technical difficulty it
went from three Muslims to two to zero
but uh after the stream of shallow it'll
be the zero Muslim streams
but um yeah so this Hadith the process
on them where he said that women are
rewarded more for praying at home but
there is a section in the mosque for
women only and it's usually divided
between a wall or a curtain or something
like that
yeah I really liked going and I would
say I've always resonated with it I
never and I don't want to sound like I'm
disrespecting Christianity when I talk
about this it's just it didn't it never
clicked for me there's a lot of things
that I'm explaining and not trying to
disrespect it but just trying to explain
like why I never felt like Christianity
spoke to me for example like there's a
hierarchy in Christianity they have well
in Catholicism those they have Bishops
they have priests they have the pope
there's like a power structure like
politics in the religion which makes no
sense correct me if I'm wrong but in
Islam there is none this is we're all
equal We're All God's Children
yeah yeah 100
um we don't really use the word uh the
terminology children but 100 we say that
God is our master we're all their slaves
so although there will be levels like
for example the the Imam or the Sheikh
will have a certain level not over
people in sight of God but we listen to
them because they have knowledge people
like the leader of the Islamic community
we listen to them because they're
they're the leader they were kind of put
in place by God to make sure the
community's safe and they have
responsibility just like a husband has
responsibility for his wife and kids
there's a level of of authority there
but it's not that oh he's better than us
or God loves him more you can have like
a poor person who worships God who is
very loved by God because of their you
know devotion
okay and there's no hierarchy because I
I had a debate with somebody when I was
debating maybe this is a waste of time
to even go back and forth on this but
I'm just like I have so many people
angry so I I do engage I was talking
about how there's pictures of the Pope
like kissing the feet of
of night of African leaders like kissing
in in Islam that's that's Haram like you
don't kiss somebody's feet the only
person that you well the only being that
you submit to is God and that his
response was and his name is Circa his
response was that the shakes
um the shakes are always doing deals and
there there's but the the shakes they
have no foreign
they don't have a hierarchical role in
Islam they're respected in the Arabic
community but that has nothing to do
with Islam correct
yeah I mean in terms of like you know
hierarchy like the pope kind of in
Christianity is above everybody else
like they're the guy his word is almost
infallible that stuff is crazy
everyone's saying you're muted right now
I'm muted so you know let me just replay
it on YouTube okay
you're hard muted right now okay okay no
reason I'll do it in a second sounds
good on mine
yeah I think it's just I think it's just
our stream but regardless
uh yeah so there's no hierarchy in in
Islam in that sense in this in in the
way that you have in Christianity all we
have is that since these people have
knowledge
we we go to them for knowledge that's
literally the only difference between
them and us
but yeah like you said there's no
hierarchy
okay uh I have more questions
what do you think is is the the best
next steps for me to take
um obviously there's a bit and I'm sure
that you you've had uh people ask you
this like people are saying um sneako's
only doing this for clout like he's
doing this because he wants to get
acceptance from the Muslim Community
what do you think the the best next
steps are obviously like I should be
perfectly practicing I have to follow
these rules but I still like admittedly
I still like drinking I still
I I don't have the time to pray five
times a day are you supposed to take all
the steps fully are you supposed to
fully dive into it or can you like
what's what's the next move
yeah that's a beautiful question so
first and foremost God understands right
so if if God has revealed the religion
with certain rules he knows that a
person's not just gonna start praying
like that every single day
although that person should be doing
that idealistically it's not realistic
for a person to learn you know how to
recite these chapters of the Quran and
learn how to pray in a day so
realistically
the next few days the next few weeks
you're going to be learning how to pray
and you're going to be establishing your
proper understanding of Islam God the
Quran the prophet Muhammad just the
basics and the Reason by the way you
feel like you don't have time to pray
right now is because you don't know how
to pray so you'd have to learn how to
pray it's going to be a lot more lengthy
but once you learn how to pray and you
memorize everything which doesn't take
long by the way it's going to be a
natural routine part of your day so the
next steps will be learning the basics
and we'll help you with that inshallah
what I also thought was pretty
interesting and I'm not sure I want to
ask you about this what do I know you're
on YouTube so you might be
it might be difficult talking about this
but what's the general idea that Muslims
have about Judaism I know some of it I
saw some people were sending me uh clips
and images and they they even write
about it it's written they talk about
how uh the Christians and Jews all the
time in the Quran
yeah yeah there is a passage in the
Quran that says that um something along
the lines of that we will always be
closer or nearer to the Christians and
the Jews
um and evidentially that is that is very
true that is the case if you look at
like you know Palestine today and what
the IDF is doing over there uh it's very
very clear that there is a discrepancy
between our relationship with Christians
and our relationship with them because
they have a state that can enforce
certain you know discriminatory laws
against us so it's not that we're
supposed to hate you know Jews or
anything like that there's no basis for
that in the Quran to dislike them or
anything actually it tells us in the
Quran what I mentioned earlier come to
terms with people of the book you know
become like-minded with them in the
sense that you you worship one God so
that's idealistically what we're
supposed to do but
since the whole thing with Israel is
going you know what's going on people
have a hard time differentiating between
Israel and Jews and I think that is
problematic as well but we're not
supposed to like hate them or anything
that's that's absurd wait but it says in
the Quran that Muslims will always get
along better with Christians than Jews
that is that
or quote Yeah essentially essentially
do you remember what it is exactly
I can try and find it for you
but okay we're all we're all people of
the book bro we all believe that Allah
gave Revelation too Muslims with Islam
initially Judaism right and Christianity
as well but the religions have been
altered
altered by who
people
what people
so with Christianity it's we can go into
that and I'm sure you you can talk about
that when you discuss why you love
Christianity in the first place but the
religion right now as it was revealed is
not what you have today in 2023 it's not
from that no there's a lot of books uh
that were removed from the Bible like uh
I think it's called nayasia that was the
Bible yeah it has been it's been amended
a lot has the Quran been changed at all
or has this been consistency not once
matter of fact that's like that's a
promise that Allah has made in the Quran
that we will guard this from being
altered or changed at all until the very
end
do you know what was uh I think what's
the Council of nice here
the Council of niceeas is basically the
the head of the the state slash the head
of the church uh religiously at the time
so they had full say so they would get
together and literally vote on things
and they you know the idea of the
Trinity fathers on the Holy Spirit
they're all co-equal cartoon of that
stuff it didn't exist before the Council
of nazia voted it in so they actually
had say on like on a belief or
ideological level theological level you
know what is true and what is false so
they got together and they voted
um that okay Jesus is equal to the
father and the Holy Spirit is equal to
Jesus and the father who's on that
Council
I don't know names exactly but they were
um they were definitely seen as like an
authority for the people religiously
okay
oh I just got 50 from zucchini nap he
said westerners oh major apology to
Islam for being Jew Golems against them
for the last century
I do I don't agree with the phrasing but
I I do agree that I I did kind of buy
into a lot of the the Western propaganda
against Islam when I was growing up and
a lot of people in the chat can agree if
you did you where'd you grow up in in
the uh you're from Canada right yeah
both of us yeah
after 9 11 there was a big push against
Islam and we we were programmed to think
that all Muslims were terrorists for a
long time
and even though I resonated with reading
the the Malcolm X autobiography there
was still like those amount of jokes and
all that always being played in the news
and like people seeing beheadings it
painted Islam in a bad light for a long
time so I think he's right that
and there's probably a reason just like
how they manipulated the Bible that
there's a reason why they tried to
manipulate the the image of Muslims and
major news
yeah 100 I mean if you think about it
from like you know people want to talk
about the Matrix and like the state and
their agendas and stuff if you look at
it from that perspective
World War One you know in Canada they
always they give out these poppies and
always talk about you know there's this
great enemy that we defeated and we
liberated everyone and the great enemy
they were talking about were the Muslims
the Ottoman Empire and the greater
Muslim Nation you know that which was
United of them they fought against the
Muslims and they ended up winning and
everything after that they worked to
dismantle Islam as much as possible so
when you go to the Middle East you see
you know uaees here Saudi Arabia is
there
um Jordan's there Oman is there they
split up everything and they elected
different rulers so we can't unite as
one again because the Quran commands us
to because that's how we have our power
so they don't want that that was the
first step they divided us they inserted
their own political leaders and then
afterwards when they thought those
leaders were kind of trying to unite
with other nations and do all these
things they either off them or they
create some kind of instability in the
country or they they sanction them and
throw them in a hole economically and
all this stuff and in the west they want
to make sure that you know these people
don't fall for Islam or turn to Islam so
they had to one justify invading the
Middle East and two trying to make Islam
look as bad as possible
I see Christians talk about how
their idea that they're the true
religion is how much they're getting
attacked right now how much they're
getting infiltrated by LGBT how you see
the drag queens and the churches and the
the Western woke the The Matrix
basically has attacked Christianity so
much so that must mean that there's some
validity to it because it's under attack
so much in the value system is being
tested so much what do you think about
that I think I think that's such a sad
argument to make and I think with all
due respect to Christians if that's the
intellectual level of argumentation they
have it's very sad because look at
socialism socialism's attacked do we see
socialism is true now
Islam is true because of that there are
many things that people hate in the west
and they speak out against all the time
how is Islam under attack
I mean you just mentioned it you know
they they made Islam look like it's uh
well today I think I think that that
that that pretty much that's faded quite
a bit
what do you mean the the negative
reputation that Islam has oh they cut
out
really I'm still with you guys my bad
that's all good noise you think that
reputation is still as strong
depends bro it depends how you look at
it Islam's been under attack since the
time of the Prophet saws bro ever since
Revelation started coming Islam's been
on an attack
it's never changed I feel like in in
some ways it's gotten better in many
cases because mainstream figures like
Tate accepting Islam have made it a
little bit more mainstream in certain
demographics that didn't even know about
Islam and they had Prejudice views on
Islam but I feel like in other ways it's
worsened
yeah the media can only control the
minds of people so much right they can
only do so much and now with social
media coming out and people like Julian
Assange revealing and Wikileaks
revealing what America is actually doing
in the Middle East it's impossible to
keep up with this narrative that Muslims
are you know insane violent people
because you know we're around I mean I'm
in California right now you know people
who recognize me they know I'm Muslim
people who see my wife she wears hijabs
knows there you know she's a Muslim they
grew up with these people they can see
socially you can't it's it's not how the
media portrays them and a lot of them by
the way after 9 11 happened they
inquired about Islam and a lot of them
accepted Islam especially women by the
way they accepted Islam because they
looked into it found it's not what Fox
News and BBC are trying to say it is and
then they accepted it kind of just like
yourself by the way you looked into
Islam eventually you came to accept it
after once thinking it was this horrible
thing and now let me be real with you
bro I grew up a Muslim my mother wore
the hijab my whole family was a Muslim I
was scared of people with long fobes and
and long beards
growing up in a Muslim house I thought
it was a weird thing just because of
what the West was trying to scary how
like their
I didn't really I didn't really
associate any kind of threat with it
like per like something specific
but I I I did I just saw it as a scary
thing you know what I mean it's learned
behavior bro from societal conditioning
but I mean everyone's saying we're muted
again and I just checked the world muted
again yeah I got the streamer yeah I was
gonna say let's just end the stream uh I
could send you leave a comment yeah yeah
thank you brother leave a comment tell
everyone to go to sneak stream it's on
Rumble uh.com forward slash what is it
sneako yeah
rumble.com hey
good they can battle it out right now
it's Christian dominated in the chat we
need some more some more Muslims saying
nice things
absolutely absolutely what what do you
think would happen if uh the same push I
don't I don't know if I just want to
make this all about uh Christianity but
what do you think would happen if the
same push that's uh infiltrating right
now Christianity in the west if it
happened to Islam do you think that
that's ever possible what would be the
response yeah well first and foremost I
want to say that the West has done a lot
worse to Muslims than they have done to
Christians the West Was a Christian
Nation once it was built on
judeo-christian principles it's only
made the switch recently so since the
Christianity was kind of so integrated
with the state to begin with
as liberalism came and people started
moving away from Christianity
Christianity became a thing that can
change over time you know in Europe in
the west Christianity was the state and
then they switched it so people could
believe what they want in their heart
but live completely different lives they
could all they have to believe is Jesus
died for our sins and he's God and I'm
good I don't care what's moral immoral a
lot of them actually don't
and since then like we discussed them
invading the Middle East and them
dividing the Muslim Nation them doing
everything that they did post during and
post World War One they've done so much
more so much worse to the Muslim
Community even today they're trying to
fight the problem is we're we're
basically an unmoving wall we are we're
not moving that's why they're struggling
so much that's why some have given up
and at the same time with everything
that's come out we're basically the
victims and a lot of people socially see
Muslims as the victims that's why they
use terms like islamophobia because it
is you know a type of discrimination
against someone just because they
they're a Muslim so we have that on our
side as well I think that's why their
movement is is really failing but you
have the people out there that's trying
to make Islam look bad
um people in the chat are wondering how
old you guys are because you said that
you you're married
yeah I'm 22. Romy how old are you uh fan
I'm 25. you're 22 and married
yeah is that how normal is that in the
Muslim world
it's unfortunately yeah going well I'll
let you finish and then I'll jump in I
was just gonna say it's it's more normal
um
it's normalized but it's not done as
often as it should be
it's normal but it's not mainstream yeah
people still wait till they're you know
25 to 30 when Islam encourages you to
get married ASAP
yeah bro there's a Hadith with a problem
went to uh you know the shabab the youth
and the kids and he told them if you
have the ability to get married then get
married
you know if you can't then fast because
fasting is going to diminish the hunger
that loss that you have make it more
manageable and controllable you know
do you think that are you married within
the religion are you married within the
government too
um so if you just get married
islamically um that's valid and this
side in the sight of God
um
firstly I would Advocate to get married
legally as well
um and I have my own reasons for that
some people might differ 40 reasons
because that's what I completely
disagree on I don't see any advantage to
that I think I'm completely against it
though bro yeah yeah so that's a great
question so firstly
um when you speak to some Muslim women
you'll some of them find themselves in a
situation where they got married to
someone just religiously so it's not on
the books in terms of what the
government sees and then the man will
get them pregnant with multiple kids
she'll give birth to their kids and the
guy will up and just leave or he'll
marry someone else islamically and just
completely neglect his first wife and
there's no Islamic Authority that's
going to stop him from doing that
there's no you know a governmental
Authority even if it's not Muslim that's
going to stop him from doing that and
she has no kind of way out of it
obviously on the other end you have the
extreme of women leaving men taking half
their stuff and that's a problem as well
um so they're both issues but I think in
the long run
I think it's a greater evil to be honest
to leave a woman in her children your
children unguarded unproducted but
that's that's just my opinion on it
what do you think fed I agree with that
bro but I also think that there's a
there's a big
underrepresented demographic of men that
have definitely been frustrated from
having half of their stuff taken for
sure
I see what you're saying Remy is
basically saying that we should protect
women and they should have a way to so
that they're but you think that do you
think it's that it's techy rule it's
techy because we're living in the west
and Islam and Sharia law cannot be
implemented 100 and it's and legal
jurisprudence can't even be uh
implemented 100 if people don't get
religiously uh sorry legally married
like brother Rami Singh so there's
there's it's a very nuanced thing
yeah like if we lived under Islamic law
and a man left his wife or whatever
that's fine he still has to take care of
his kids and in some cases he has to
provide for her you know the bare
minimum for her to live in in some cases
for some periods of time so it's more
just
have you met Muslim guys who kind of use
that the four wives things in a slimy
way because you're talking about how
they'll get married is you're smiling so
probably I don't know why you look but
it has is that a common thing that
happens
um
it it does happen
um I don't think it happens as often
it's not so much about them getting a
second wife even though that does occur
it's more so about them leaving their
first wife and then getting another
first wife because he's technically not
married anymore but that does exist as
well sometimes um where a man will you
know get a second wife and um but that's
not wrong islamically speaking you know
if he does get a second wife he doesn't
need his wife's permission or anything
to do that
what is uh what's the thoughts about
taxation uh interest loans one thing
that made me resonate a lot with it when
I was still seeking was the fact that
they see these I mean ultimately these
are Jewish inventions for the most part
interests on loans taxation
borrowing money that this these were
invented by the the Jewish the bankers
but most of them were were Jewish and
that's why they controlled the banks of
so long in Europe Islam it's written in
the Quran that that's
completely wrong is that true yeah it's
completely unequivocally wrong and by
the way even in Judaism it's supposed to
be illegal
um for the record I don't know exactly
where but it has been ran either in
their their book of law or in the uh the
Old Testament somewhere that they're not
supposed to do it either so I don't know
why they jumped on that but yeah
what about child support is that
is you're basically advocating towards
marriage so that women are have
protection should we
still
should we still pay child support too
um it's something that is reasonable
right I think it should be the bare
minimum for what the kid needs
um or that which the man can give
um
but it really depends a lot of these
things are on a case-by-case basis
you'll have an Islamic called the a
judge
hear both sides see the situation
evaluate it as per what's in the Quran
and what the prophet peace be upon Him
taught us and then come to a decision on
that but generally speaking the
responsibility of taking care of the
kids
um so long as there are you know either
they're unmarried women the father has
to take care of them or a child a man
under the age of puberty the father has
to take care of him as well
and both of you like you said you know
basic basic uh basic needs that type of
stuff it doesn't have to be anything
elaborate you see a lot of uh people in
the kofar world you know they they you
know get with an athlete or whatever
they divorce take out their stuff and
now you got you know they secured the
bag they're getting 50 million a month
to buy diapers wet wipes and formula bro
this is not it they don't need that much
money so Islam comes in and and
establishes Authority in the in the
basis of what's reasonable too bro Allah
has never made any commandment that's
that's too far out there and it doesn't
it doesn't sit right with us you know
what I mean
yeah what are your thoughts on
because um obviously I think that and I
want to see everybody in the chat say
free Palestine what's happening is
completely unjust and it's censored and
what what they show in the media is
extremely biased but basically I I think
everybody in who's watching this knows
the
but
for the most part it's like
I believe that they're the chosen people
that they deserve this land and so
people from Poland Hungary uh they came
from Europe and they just they displaced
a lot of these Palestinian Palestinians
uh because of what was written in their
book I think that's completely unjust
and they're a lot of people but it's
basically that that's the idea that that
conflict pretty much encapsulates
um what a lot of people can
equate to
I'm gonna be very careful with my words
because someone's gonna clip this
opponent on Twitter well what are your
thoughts about
there's a clear difference between
politicals
I think political something that's
backed by these fermented by the IDF is
completely horrendous because of the
result of it all you know them throwing
literally Supreme Court notices eviction
notices to Palestinian people who have
been there for Generations or families
have owned that land in the house for
Generations they're just kicked out for
some random half European guy or someone
who just maybe even converted to
now they have Israeli citizenship and
they're like a level above them it
doesn't make any sense I think that you
know they should have a right to stay in
the Holy Land I think that they should
have a right to have their own land as
well just like I believe Muslims should
but to strip the land from you know
Palestinian people and then to persecute
them in this way I think is is atrocious
so any takes a form of that is horrible
but and he just takes the form of
basically you could have the right to
their own land I have no problem with
that
so where would they go
so Ashley that's that's interesting they
were there I forget the exact place I
think it was Uganda but they were they
were offered a place in Africa first
they're not going to Uganda yeah that's
the thing that's the thing so they said
no and after the Palestinians were so
hospitable to them and they took them
and they protected them during you know
World War II and stuff after that they
basically completely took over by help
of Britain and people who had no right
to give the land to them
what about you uh Fair what are your
thoughts on
first of all bro
and before you answer them
you love humble oh yeah we're on Roblox
so YouTube you you can't talk about a
lot of this stuff on YouTube you can bro
you can we can we can't like when you
ask me this question I was automatically
like oh do I say do I not it's YouTube
bro
yeah I I really I noticed a lot of
things like talking to Muslims on
Twitter uh shout out to this guy Xavier
I forgot his last name but it's just
like I'm just seeing the similarities in
how a lot of people are have similar
beliefs but like me asking you do this
right now
how different is your answer going to be
on camera as it would be off camera
well it feels like it's off camera on
Rumble okay good
but honestly man
uh everything that Rami said so far I
agree with and I do believe that
because
everything we believe is conditioned and
programmed by the media and a lot of
those big forces in power are controlled
by
well we're going to be fed about them is
is definitely far from the truth I can't
even go to the gym bro without seeing
the news and seeing how you know
when how they're so innocent and how
they're just the victims and how Muslims
are the perpetrators bro and it just
makes me think like do do people
generally not do their own homework like
is everyone just a sheep is everyone
really a sheep because I know there's
people like you know yourself you've
been mentioning how since you were a kid
you've always been kind of thinking out
of the box and you read the
autobiography of Malcolm X that kind of
in a way segued you into looking into
Islam but do you generally think that
most people today
have not I guess had these realizations
within them and that they're past the
point of even saving
yes I and I think with faith that's
where if you're Guided by a specific
Faith you're you're going to see a lot
of these control mechanisms that they
use
now being more centered and having a
more clear world view you notice how
there are so many different ways so many
different lies that you believe in when
you are clueless and when you say like
you're I'm spiritual like I'm astrology
like they you're so easily scammed and
programmed and you don't see past a lot
of the lies and I get kind of upset now
like how did I how did I ever believe in
that and it's because you don't have a
clear faith that directs you like for
example the
the Amish people the Amish people have a
clear Faith obviously that you we could
argue whether or not it's a false
religion but they have a clear Faith
they believe it they have their own
Community they're not affected by the
outside world they're not affected by
the major news and they never put on
they never got they didn't get they
don't they don't watch any of the news
so they don't take birth control they
don't have any feminism they don't
listen to garbage music making them
twerk they have none of these program
mechanisms and they're happy they see
the craziness like people come in with
iPhones and be like why are you not
wearing them and they're like we're fine
we build our homes and we're we're not
part of this we're they they see how
crazy we are and they think that we're
insane and for so long we're like these
people must be crazy because they don't
have iPhones they never had
they were separated completely from that
they're never brainwashed so I think
that with faith it's easier to be more
centered and be able to see a lot of
these these program mechanisms because
ultimately if you don't have a specific
faith if you don't have uh if you don't
have if you don't believe in
um if you don't believe in God then
someone else is going to replace that
for you if you are Godless and say you
want to be an actor or you want to be a
rapper then your God becomes a celebrity
it becomes the most famous rapper it
becomes the most famous actor you end up
worshiping those people because you you
all you need something to submit to and
so people will choose Fame to submit to
or they'll choose music or they'll
choose lust they'll there's always
something that replaces that and I think
when you when you see the world from
that lens that you need to have
something to submit to and that it must
the best thing to submit to must be the
one creator of the universe that's that
makes the most sense just logically the
universe had to be created by some by
someone and we shouldn't worship a man
because men are equal to us
at when you that's that's how I I think
I'm thinking more clearly than I ever
have before that this is the most um
this is the most logical way to to
approach the world and I feel more ready
than ever to
to have children and to and to continue
to my my growth as a man but yeah I
don't I don't think most people are are
ever going to think outside the box
because of all of the amount of
distractions I've had it too like you'll
know you will see someone and you've
definitely seen people you're in Canada
which is one of the most brainwashed bot
places in the like they they look they
submit to the government they love
control Canadians love they love being
told what to do by Daddy government that
is their God and those types of people
you'll see them they'll just sit here
and you'll hear the noise of tick tock
blasting out for out
and they have no time to think for
themselves so by the time that they turn
off the app and two hours have gone by
their brain is emptier they're kind of
foggy they're looking around and then
whatever what's next Vape you know to
work send a bunch of Snapchat it's just
it's more garbage and
I think the best way to to tell people
who who don't realize what's happening
is is
just just
I I don't wanna I don't want to tell
people to convert but
just I think
no these people because it's not most
people are not going to be able to
convert overnight but you need to
analyze like everything in your life and
what you're doing and think about if
it's if it has a positive or negative
effect on you I don't think even people
think about that I don't think people
analyze their actions every single day
what go what's going on in their head I
you know what I like about Islam too
music is Haram because music is
programming I I and ever since I
realized that I'll go to the gym and
I'll hear the music that they're playing
and like you could put on noise
canceling but you have to listen to it
so I'm listening to it and you just hear
every single one of the lyrics like even
this Bruno Mars song which I I liked
when I was a kid it's like uh today I
don't feel like doing anything the lazy
song yeah I just wanna lay in my bed and
it's like yeah but then you listen to
what he always
decide but in Christianity you say that
it's just advocating for sloth he's
saying how
how to do nothing to sit down I just
want to be lazy lay in my bed and
picking up the phone leave the message
at the tone because today I'm doing
nothing nothing at all and it's just
nothing that is how you become a slave
you do nothing and then someone's gonna
tell you what to do and that's that's
why I agree with uh right Islam fixes a
lot of the problems in the west
um let me ask you this little this whole
journey of finding one thing that you
are a slave to whether it's music
whether it's drugs whether it's concerts
or whatever
and making this one being that you
submit to Allah God
how was your journey into this I really
want to know this because Allah says in
the Quran that sometimes there's many
people that are you know astray and
Allah will allow them to be further
astrayed because of their own miss you
know wrongdoings and all that and at
that point it's kind of difficult to
kind of unplug from The Matrix so what
helped you and how was your journey to
find that one being to submit to to be
Allah you guys saw it so I actually want
to thank you guys uh Rami and fed you're
in here and he's in France the third one
I forgot his name I don't know sorry
about that but you you I would say like
conversations like this I wanted to say
it's been a year since I started live
streaming it's been I started daily live
streaming one year ago
um yesterday and that Journey just kind
of being degenerate I was smoking not
having a clear Direction and just like
kind of upset that feeling that I was
programming not knowing what was going
on it took a year it was a year of
having these conversations with guys
like you of traveling the world talking
to different people seeking out the
right information and I'll always seek
it through through comedy and
entertainment and it took a year to get
to that point and uh you you saw a big
part of that Journey like especially
when I was
um when we had that stream after I got
in trouble for for mocking the prayer
and stuff like that and that that helped
me go going through that publicly helped
me I think go through that Journey
faster her because you get the response
from everybody you have constant debates
you're around more people you're
constantly having these types of
conversations you have to challenge your
your psyche a lot of people will choose
to just live in ignorance ignorance is
bliss they don't want to have to
challenge these things they get
complicated there's this reason that
there's the sentiment of the west where
you say you never discuss your salary
you never discuss politics you don't
talk about religion on it so what what
are you going to talk about what else is
there to talk about besides money
besides God besides what's going on in
the world anything else is a waste of
energy is a waste of your voice but they
tell us that because they want you to
have mindless conversations where you're
just talking about celebrities you're
talking about sports you know who won
the this and you're talking about other
people's achievements and then you have
nothing so I I think within this year it
took 365 days and even from the
beginning I I resonated a lot with it
because I was extremely extremely tired
I was living in New York City at the
time of how you see the people brought
to Pride parades and like one in three
people right now in New York City I
don't know if there's anybody in the
chat you walk around Manhattan one in
three people you have no idea what
gender they are you don't know what they
are they're walking around with dyed
hair
pretty body they have all jewelry and
they're just like this yeah yeah what
are you what are you that's like one in
three people now and I'm living in this
and like this is not right and I will go
to a coffee shop and then they have a
giant poster and they say we don't use
pronouns and I'm just like trying to
order and I'm just like what it what
what does this have to do with my I just
want a coffee and then you get the
coffee and it's terrible and it's like
mocha and it has all this weird GM it's
like what am I drinking this is is this
gonna make me a gender pronoun person I
don't wanna
so getting upset about that at first but
also I want to recommend because I have
a lot of angry people who watch My
Stream uh if you ever see my chat my
chat has a reputation of being angry
upset I would say that there are some
incels who watch it I don't say that as
a derogatory term but it's true people
are upset with what they have been
programmed to believe but you can't be
in that red pill rage phase forever you
need to actively try to get out of that
I think you guys saw me at that every
day I was just screaming at the camera
like what's going on like why did I
believe in all this stuff why did I
quarantine why did and but the the point
is is to get out of that and to find a
real solution I I think the the right
solution uh for me and if anybody
resonates with me I think it's uh
submission to the the one true creator
beautifully said man well honestly bro
I'm very very proud of you
um we did see the journey
and we did see the um the growth and I
think that it is a beautiful thing we we
always talk about on our show that um
one extreme will always birth The Other
Extreme you know red pill is a reaction
to extreme feminism
which was a reaction to maybe extreme
misogyny once upon a time or I mean I
don't really believe that full whole
Harley but we can talk about that
another day but you know for red pill
for example was a reaction
um liberalism was a reaction to being
held down by the government or by the
church at the time
so this red pill rage that you're
discussing people it's natural for them
because it's just a reaction to
the being blue pill I think actually me
and five probably went through that
stage as well and at the beginning we
started a Channel about red pill and
Islam
um and then actually you learned that
red pill islamically is is wrong because
although it might have some good or some
truth if it has something that's good
because it relates to Islam then you
don't need it throw it away just
practice Islam as soon as you introduce
another man-made ideology you've you've
contradicted yourself especially because
there are things in red pill that
contradict is stem inevitably man major
time bro big time things in red pill
yeah yeah so it's beautiful and I think
that inshallah you amongst many others
can be great role models for people who
maybe are a little misguided they need
to see people practice Islam
um representation is a huge part of it
you know Allah says in the Quran that he
made the prophet peace be upon him the
perfect example for us the perfect
example so when we see people like
yourself and like Andrew Tate and and
other young people who you know they
weren't Muslim Once Upon a Time and now
they are people who are respectable in
the online community it's really really
big people quoting verses like you know
this world is temporary enjoyment this
temporary delusion you know that's
exactly what you just said without using
that exact verbiage you're basically
describing people are distracting
themselves with this useless stuff oh
what's on what's on the news today oh
you know the Lakers just won
um you know oh let's watch this movie
together let's scroll on Tick Tock for
two hours straight and become mindless
you know that's all temporary delusional
enjoyment
um whereas true contentment true
happiness and true purpose is as you
mentioned in worshiping one God alone
and that's why God says in the Quran
those who believe and whose hearts are
content with the remembrance of God
indeed when you remember that when you
remember Allah when you remember God the
hearts will find ease and contentment
I have to defend red pill and I I do
agree with pretty much everything you
said but
I have to defend red pill because you
have to understand it it's for a lot of
guys in the west it's just the the best
solution to a problem you're right it's
a reaction to feminism it's a reaction
to this girl boss mentality and it gives
men a way to navigate through
through a society that is against them
that's actively trying to make them
weaker Islam fixes that because men are
are told to and Muhammad's a g like
Muhammad peace be upon him he was he was
a businessman he was a political leader
he was a really strong man and Islam
values and respects masculinity there's
no toxic masculine it's not ashamed and
you're supposed to be strong there's a
lot of things like you can't wear like
you can't have a small little
um you can't swear I'm not trying not to
swear but you can't have a [__] little
dog a little squirky Chihuahua because
that's Haram that's a waste of time it's
like an object of beauty am I correct
you're supposed to have like a big guard
dog
yeah if you do have a if you do have a
dog it has to have a purpose like being
a guard dog yeah right I used to wear a
gold chain but wearing gold is that
that's it's there we go
I wanted to say it was gay but that's
that's why because you're wearing I'm
trying to change my terminology
um well here's the thing you think it's
gay but you know I'm not gonna say it's
because it's gay but the basis is
because it's imitation of women bro
okay that's what's Haram yeah okay okay
fair so I took off the gold chain
because you're not supposed to work am I
don't have to take off the watch too
no not that I know if it's not gold
right no no you should be good let me
let me double check for you let me let
me ask my teacher and double check but
I'm pretty sure be good okay yeah talk
to Shooter bro when we travel to uh
Dubai and hung out with shooter he had
sold all of his gold watches bro and he
was showing us his collection and how
you know it's all silver now and I was
like a little about it bro he made that
big step I wore a gold chain every
single day for about eight years and
just when I heard that took it off no I
don't care I don't care go I look good
gold looks good but I I don't want to I
want to stay consistent with it but yeah
to defend red pill it gives men and
it gives men a way out it gives them
something to follow especially like
imagine think about it like imagine like
the average and so the average guy
confused like like how I was at that at
that time like when you're around all
this wokeness what's an easier immediate
solution is it Islam or is it red pill
or is it something that gives you you
know more like red pill will give you
more confidence like once you you
realize how to talk to women when you
get over that hump of being like angry
that you can't talk to them it gives you
a way to to not to see through the
programming and not let you become
weaker because they're they're telling
you to become weaker it does fix a lot
of immediate problems and at the same
time
like in social situations for example
like I I went on a big business trip
around Europe everybody's drinking you
know and then people will look at you in
a certain that's stupid yeah it's stupid
to justify drinking that way but you
gotta understand why people gravitate
towards the red pill immediately
we'll do in person one day all three of
us or all four of us but yeah I feel I
see what you're saying and I do agree
right I'm not I'm not saying red pill is
completely bad I'm just saying that uh
since there are aspects of it you can
find in the Islam at the point of kind
of diversion someone should choose Islam
but I feel you 100 we don't have Muslims
going and propagating this idea of
masculinity in the way that red pill
people do I think obviously they do take
it to an extreme because this is
something that's man-made and it's going
to have flaws but you know I went down
that path as well you know I tried to
get married once yeah you think I'm too
young at 22. I tried to get married at
18. right so I was I was close to it in
my own head
um and it Flocka didn't work out and you
know that that broke my heart I was what
red people would call to some blue
pilled guy and you know I thought
everything was sunshine and rainbows and
women are Immaculate and like all that
stuff yeah
um and then I did fall for the like the
kind of red pill stuff you know it tells
you very basic things work out get your
money up be a good man
um uh get lots of women blah blah
through being dominant and top tier and
high level and high value
um and then it starts pushing you in
some some of it of a weird Direction
um kind of a to be honest disrespect
towards women degeneracy in yourself and
of women as well because I mean think
about it like this there's a clear
contradiction just on the basic level of
red pill you think women should not be
sleeping around with with random men
because that's degenerate but at the
same time a high value man can sleep
around with many different women or can
sleep around with many different people
they're not sleeping with other men
they're sleeping with other women which
means for you to be a high value man
that's exercising his high value-ness by
being with women you need women that are
also going to be degenerate so even if
you yourself don't think men sleeping
around is degenerate you're definitely
creating the women that are you're
definitely using the women that are so
that's like me saying you know alcohol
is horrible while I'm sitting here
drinking it say okay cool but yeah
you're you're either exposing a
contradiction in your belief or you're
just showing that you're a hypocrite to
be frank and then on top of that they
have this myth of the beta meal provider
bro what the hell is that because in
Islam Allah tells us that we must
provide and protect for our women now
I'm not saying you got to provide for
just any girl that gives you attention
though but your wife bro that's earned
that level of devotion and loyalty and
commitment for me bro you're not going
to provide for her because you don't
want to seem like a simp how does that
make any sense bro and it just red pill
comes from a stem of insecurity at the
end of the day you're you're masking one
secure insecurity with another generally
getting on self-improvement and trying
to put truth in your life as like the
Cornerstone is going to lead you to
Islam bro it's not going to lead you
into red pill
and in a sense I see it as just
the red pill is just
um there's an echo but I see it as a
just representation of realizing the
truth it doesn't have to be one thing
encompassing but it's a reaction to
feminism because feminism is a lie it's
a reaction to the programming because
the programming was not made in our best
interest it was made to keep us as
slaves it doesn't have to uh there's an
echo on um
this camera
I think he's back now is that better or
yeah I think we're good now we got a 20
uh Donut from Nacho SWAT he said my
family is Christian I'll be converting
to Islam this changed the way I looked
at life learning a lot thank you my
brother's getting better every day
thanks a lot man
yeah
family as well I think that's that's one
of the things about Islam it's like in
life perspective is everything right I
always use this example so I'll say it
again you know I'm gonna start with the
story and it's going to sound bad but
let me give a context so one day I was
at Walmart with my wife and there was an
old lady who was in the middle of the
doorway and who wouldn't move so I
pushed her right that sounds bad but
it's the truth what I really mean is she
was in one of those little like electric
scooters and the wheel got stuck in the
concrete because there's a pothole so I
pushed the scooter because she was in
the middle of the doorway and wanted to
help her go so the first version is true
but the second version you have more
context you have a new perspective on it
Islam gives you that New Perspective
Islam lets you know listen
it actually is summarized beautifully
with the versatile Quran have you seen
the one who takes his own desires as his
God
what does this mean this means that God
is the one who we are supposed to obey
in every Regard in life
as soon as you obey something other than
God you started to worship that thing if
you listen to your mom and dad for every
single thing that they tell you to do
you basically worship them if you listen
to the government for every little thing
they tell you to do you basically
worship them if you listen to your own
sexually you know sexual reproductive
system and your your hunger and all
these things that drive you okay then
you worship your own desires and you're
no better in one in the words of one um
the cousin of the Prophet peace upon him
basically you're like the animals
because that's they do the same exact
thing they feel something they act on it
if are are you going to be on the same
level as a dog that they feel something
and they go and do it are you going to
use the rationality intellect that God
gave you and the guidance he gave you to
decipher what's good and what's bad
it's almost subhuman and I love the
point that brother Romney brought up in
the beginning where it's like you're
sleeping around with a bunch of women
that are degenerate that you deem not
wifeable not wife worthy right did
there's 304s or whatever and then you
have other girls that you categorize as
a wife but in the process of dealing
with women in the in the former manner
you're creating more women that are not
wifey so I love that point because
you're left with a society that you
yourself are basically deeming as
degenerate but you are causing that so
it's not a solution it's not a solution
oriented it's reactionary and there's
many benefits in red pill I'm going to
say this like first and foremost we all
know this just like there's many
benefits and many other ways of life but
it doesn't mean it's going to be over
encompassing as the whole truth and the
problem with these things is many human
beings lack the mental faculties to draw
the line between what is too far because
red pill generally goes into one extreme
of mgtel and then you got all these
people that are just sleeping with blow
up dolls and we know through Islam that
clearly Allah tells us that we as human
beings don't have the full picture so
instead of leaving mankind to kind of
figure things out in man-made ideologies
that yes sometimes there's good but then
there's bad and then they all say oh
take the bad with the good or take the
good with the bad Islam is all good so
why not just submit to something that
can't do you any wrong
that's a great point and
but I think at the same time that a lot
of men need to and you talked about how
you went through the red pill Journey
too I think men need to have a reference
point to understand to not do it anymore
like we could say this and I I agree
that it's the truth but Mo pretty much
all men are still going because we're
imperfect we sin we are going to act on
on these urges regardless out of
curiosity or out of uh ego or reaction
or just because it's out there a lot of
guys need to just get it out of their
system in order to to fully obey
is that do you think that's true or even
as I'm saying it I I started to disagree
with that I think I think islamically we
know clearly we don't need to just get
out of our system but I think that as as
products of Western civilization and
society that are already kind of
embedded into that and have not been
programmed correctly by Islam from the
jump
yes we might need to know the night to
know the day but I do want to know what
Romney has to say about that yeah so
firstly I I really appreciate the point
you made and I think it's very important
that I that I mentioned that there's a
lot of red pills spokesman for a red
pill and they're they're great speakers
they make great points and and a lot of
young men resonate with them because
they've been through what they've been
through and um they can relate to them
on on a lot of you know many different
levels and I think there's a lack of
young Muslim men who are being those
role models in the same way that are
doing the same thing you know reptile
communities doing in terms of
masculinity and Brotherhood except
replacing red pill with Islam so I I see
where you're saying with that and I do
agree on that end but
I I islamically obviously I don't agree
with people needing to get out of their
systems before they convert I think
that's kind of just a scapegoat
obviously we want to right but Allah
says in the Quran it's it's possible
that you love a thing that's bad for you
and that you hate a thing and it's good
for you you don't know when God knows so
at the end of the day I think what's
what's really important is
I'll give an example I spoke to young
men and he was telling me that he wants
to be celibate he's not super religious
he's not Muslim but he was telling me
about this and he said I just can't
exactly get over the fence and I told
him listen you have to understand why
you're doing it you can't just be
celibate to be celibate because
everything in your body is going to tell
you to not be celibate and to go you
know be with this woman that woman you
have to understand why Islam gives you
the why so you don't see it before you
accept Islam because all you see is what
I want my urges once you understand
Islam and once you actually like believe
even if you don't accept it even if you
like at least believe in it in your
heart
then you're going to start to see a lot
of these things as bad anyways now I'm
going to be honest I'm a man I have
urges I love women I think they're
beautiful I actually don't have the urge
to go out and sleep with random women in
the street I don't because my love for
God is so much more than my love for you
know doing that
and this time gives away out you know it
says get married you want be you want to
be politicians be politician get married
to all of them and take care of all of
them there's no problem
if you feel I didn't answer no words no
you didn't completely answer it and I'm
just remembering I was in Europe and
I went to this
event basically I was speaking at this
event with a lot of young entrepreneurs
and I would say 80 of them
are only fans managers pretty much all
like 80 of them which is you know and I
actually I was debating them about this
at once and I forgot that they were all
I was talking about how only fans
managers are not contributing to the
world and they're making men sadder and
then I'm like I was in a circle and
they're all this like no no I'm like I'm
debating it's me versus eight pimps
right now and I'm talking about how only
defense is bad they're like no they
they're getting happy after they jerk
off I'm like come on what about in an
hour what about in a week when the bank
account is drained they know they know
it's not good but they're it's
justifications and at one point where
we're at this party I actually I
genuinely like pretty much all the
people that were there I think they're
I I like to see the good in people
but it was it was a very
low energy environment and it another
thing about their character but
living for just money living for lust
and you know making men weaker while you
reap the benefits you're gonna have
you're gonna not be
as your energy is on a different
frequency does that make sense like
you're not gonna be
and I I really felt that way I was also
drinking and you know I I'm trying to to
get past that but
it was very clear like in that
environment that these people that this
was not a Godly place right you could
have certain conversations like in the
mosque for example I recommend anybody
especially all the Christians that are
upset in the chat it doesn't mean I'm
not saying that just because I want you
to convert just step into a mosque and
just just see just to see it for
yourself because the the second I just
went there for the first time second I
stepped in there you can you feel like
all you could feel the prayer you could
feel how people's prayers were answered
you could tell that there was some
essence of God in that room
just just even if you would close your
eyes and you walked in there I swear to
you you would feel the difference
something about that must be real even
for the atheists I I really I really
recommend you do it and I like the fact
that there's not there was there's
nothing in a mosque uh correct me if I'm
wrong besides just like you have the the
prayer mat and you have the the
beautiful walls and then you have the um
the place to wash yourself in the
bathroom and that's it right that's
that's the main thing yeah but the main
thing bro is you got a lot of Malaika
angels and you can feel that in the air
when you're surrounded by Angels bro
it's almost like you can feel the
blessings as soon as you walk through
the door have you felt the that's that's
exactly what happened when I when I
walked in
um did you go with shooter bro I did
that's amazing and the mosque across the
street is beautiful that was the one
yeah yeah we went with uh Dylan Madden
too oh he went yeah we took him bro we
tried to radicalize him did he did he
revert
I'm not sure bro
he's still kind of toting the line
because uh
yeah it's you don't want to I I don't
know my guess is because you don't want
to alienate a lot of people like you
probably don't want to get that reaction
like even if he did revert privately you
don't want to announce that publicly
because like people get really upset
about that but so yeah because shooter
bro shooter did Reverb back in
Philippines you mentioned that on a
podcast and he said that it wasn't until
you know weeks later that he finally did
it at the Masjid but if from if you have
anything to say um let us know because I
have a big question that many people
have been asking no I'm good go for it
bro okay Bismillah so do you believe
snico the today a lot of influencers are
accepting Islam because
it's an antidote to degeneracy and they
seem that liberalism is not the answer
blue pill is not the answer feminism is
not the answer and because these things
are not the answer I'm just going to go
to the opposite of falsehood which is
Islam the truth
but it's it's almost because Islam is
anti-feminism and anti-liberalism and
anti-matrix that I'm gonna accept it not
because I actually believe it to be the
truth do you find any truth to this with
a lot of influences today of course but
I don't think that that means that
they're doing it just because it's it's
trendy uh it's and because I I think
that's more proof of
um I think that's more proof of the
Quran and how it stood the test of time
because if if it if people are realizing
all the lies and they're gravitating
towards something that is completely
against that they there must be that
they're finding their way to the truth
mm-hmm
and I see I see talk from from Muslims
all the time saying that influencers are
using this for credibility I don't who
who
I guess like you could say me
who else is like really
Tristan and Andrew I I don't there's all
these influences are I don't see them
who I don't know who's like reverting on
that level
yeah yeah I agree I I think I I don't
think someone would accept Islam for
Khloe maybe there are some people that
look into Islam for clout whatever but
anyone who accepts Islam they're
stepping into the line of fire you think
Andrew Tate was was heavily scrutinized
for accepting Islam you're being heavily
scrutinized by some Christians for
accepting Islam it's not like a popular
thing to do maybe it'll get you
um you know a few views for a day or so
but it's not like it's a whole life
commitment and what I've seen from
shooter and what I've seen online from
Andrew what I can even see from you is
that you guys are very genuine and
sincere and by the way any Muslim who
comes and says oh they're doing it for
clout that's not how a Muslim behaves
there's a very clear Hadith of the
Prophet peace be upon him so I'm going
to share it because it's actually crazy
one man was fighting a battle literally
fighting a war and he's coming out of
man with a sword and the man
basically says I testified that there's
one God worthy of worship and that the
prophet Muhammad is a messenger he
accepted Islam on the spot and the
Muslim at the time during that battle he
killed the guy then he went and told the
prophet what happened and he's like
the process time he's like did you kill
him after you accepted Islam and he's
like yeah but he just did it so I
wouldn't kill him he did it because he
was scared I had a sword and Pastor
salaam said did you cut open his heart
and see what was inside of it
that is the the degree of of love that
we should have for people that accept
Islam we shouldn't be going this weird
garbage speculation oh he's doing it for
views and this and that do you what like
do you honestly wish to push someone
further away from Islam even if someone
did accept this time for abuse or
whatever
that's okay no problem because now that
they say they're a Muslim if anything
they're going to look into Islam and
find the truth in it regardless
and there's many benefits bro it's
multifaceted like if they accept number
one if they accept Islam today for Dunya
like just the world or cloud or Trend or
whatever Iman right their proper strong
faith might actually enter their heart
tomorrow and it's okay and if they're an
influencer it's in and of itself that
they're looking into Islam or becoming
Muslim even if let's say God forbid
they're not sincere with it then
hundreds of thousands of more people are
going to look into Islam now because
they put Islam on that platform that
they have
foreign
I think it's good that you have a lot of
Muslims criticizing and being protective
of their religion because it makes you
want to be better I've seen a lot of
angry women with hijabs on Twitter and
their profile picture and they're
they're very upset and they're they're
saying things like
um sneakers degenerate blah blah I I
think it's necessary for that to happen
and I I think it's it's just part of the
process because you see that and then
you're able to criticize and
self-analyze and and just want to be
better in reaction to that and and to
not and to be able to to be bigger than
that criticism I don't think it's a bad
thing at it that's why I'm not really
offended by it or I don't really take
um a problem with that and I I think
ultimately if you if you Embrace any
religion then you know it true to your
heart so look whatever you see online
that's one thing but
I mean it's it's really at that point
it's just between you and God that's the
only who really knows your true
intentions and anyone else speculating
that's not really your business nor can
you do anything about that
yeah yeah 100 100 I think that's a great
point it only really becomes a problem
with somebody is they're not strong
enough to deal with it you know what I
mean as soon as they feel like
ostracized a little bit they'll kind of
run the other direction
um so I I could see that 100
so how how many days have you been a
Muslim for
I guess um
I I would say I revert I said the words
and everything when I went to the mosque
but I was pretty private about it for a
while and I did because I you know
trying to
you know as a public figure whatever you
don't want to seem like you just look
what I just did I just want something
like you know it so I was pretty private
about it I've been I've been reading
more and I think it's been about a month
it's been wow
that's amazing man that's that's
beautiful so what would you say and I
know you discussed it a bit but what
would you say is the biggest difference
now that you're a Muslim in your life
the biggest difference is
sometimes I would have these moments
where I would
I would
feel down and I would just like lay down
in bed like but I kind of just numb
to think because I I used to be a
nihilist for a long time
I I really believed in nothing I even
made videos like uh back on YouTube
before I even started streaming it's
hard to find these videos now but made a
video called nothing happens for a
reason and that was a response to this
video I made it called everything
happens for reason basically I said like
nothing matters who cares and I I was I
had this like this dark time for a while
because I didn't see any like proper
Role Models I didn't see anybody who was
supposed to look up to we pretty much
had to listen to the government I didn't
believe in them and I was kind of just
like pretty upset about everything and
I'm like [__] everyone I don't care
about anything nothing matters I'm just
gonna do drugs and cope and nothing
matters like my impact on the world it
this is genuinely you're you're I but
this is what I was thinking and I was
like I was echoing this I was making
videos about this
um
and then even even like before that
recently I was just like I'd have these
moments like just nothing whatever
nothing matters but now like having a
specific faith and a belief it's just
you don't want to waste any time I've
been more efficient and I would say I'm
more awake I'm less tired
I have a clear purpose I want to be more
mature and I'm thinking about marriage
and and how I want to raise my children
more just I want to have a more clear
direction for my future this this is
General if anybody watching has this
phase whether they think that nothing
matters and they're they're kind of
nihilistic and they don't care about
anything I think a good first step is to
is to looking into Islam because that
will give you a clear direction for
exactly what you're supposed to do and
the Quran there are there's a guidebook
for for how you're supposed to live your
life it just it tells you everything
that you're supposed to do when it
especially if you look at the life of
Muhammad if you're a man you you could
see the blueprint for how you should how
you should live your life
um in terms of business in terms of
leadership how you conduct yourself
how to speak to people like that guy
really lived at he was a g like in every
in every aspect so I I think that the
answers
um a lot of people gravitate towards
self-help books but they're all saying
the same thing that the other self-help
books are saying what is it like the
subtle art of not giving a [__] like
yeah you need to not care what people
think that's a very surface level part
of getting over that stuff it's just
like you need to be confident like okay
48 Laws of Power these stuff up books
are really really surface level stuff
that just it helps you navigate social
situations and basically as I'm saying
it is very similar to the red pill in a
way where it's just a small solution to
a bigger problem
I I recommend
I recommend looking into the Quran
zero sneako all these self-help books
and man-made ideologies they make you
seem like you're the center of the
universe
when you accept Islam you understand
you're nothing bro you're literally
nothing and Allah is the center of
everything and it's because of Allah
that we have everything that we have
do you get what I mean
exactly you start seeing yourself as
like the main character and you're
trying to play games with people and
being manipulative it's not a good way
to live seeing understanding in Islam
that we're all equal
and nobody is better than us we are all
just people and and God is the real
creator that in a sense the way you say
it it's like we're nothing it kind of
gives you makes me happy in a way where
you can let go of your ego that you
don't need to compete with other people
you you want to live the happiest life
and you you want to be able to serve God
because he created everything that we
have that's that's the most important
role that we could play as people
I know bro look at look at women bro and
we have so much love for our Muslim
sisters and Mila you know
allow them to overcome their you know
issues and hurdles with hijab the ones
that are struggling with hijab but look
at the women the Muslim sisters that
have finally overcome the shackles that
society places on them man-made
expectations to literally Market their
sexuality and Beauty bro just for just
for Benjamin's bro and they these
sisters are the ones that can finally
taste the sweetness of Liberation and
empowerment yet you got all these women
bro caped up Caked Up like a cupcake bro
you could take a wet wipe and just 99 of
their face is gone bro with one swipe
these are the women going around and
it's not a Jabba you know sisters that
still wear makeup but the ones that are
just following these Trends and they
can't go outside unless they're
basically half naked these women are the
ones that are going outside saying
they're empowered they're liberated
they're free
that's not Freedom bro
no that's actually they're they're more
they're slaves they're slaves so that's
the definition of Oppression bro but
then they're going to look at a woman a
Muslim sister in hijab or in the club
and they're going to say look how look
how oppressed and brainwashed and
old-fashioned she is bro
like do you not see the cognitive
dissonance
yeah I think the best way to describe it
is like they are the women who cover
themselves they're they're submitting to
God because they they don't want to be
objects of of Beauty for random people
and the the people who are half the
women who are half naked they are
they're slaves to their own ego to their
own lusts and
and to the system that is that is
encouraging it it's not it's it's either
I see it as simple as this like who who
do you want to submit to for anybody who
doesn't agree with this what is the best
idea to submit to would it be the
creator of the universe would it be to
at the entertainment industry would it
be to the the music would it be to the
government
very simple like would it be to another
man would it be to a celebrity the the
best for you and for the world would
just be to submit to the Creator
it's it's just it's it's
um logically nothing else makes sense to
me anymore why why Run To Creation when
we have the Creator bro and Romney if
you want bro take this opportunity and
just in a nutshell do you want to
summarize Islam for anyone that has no
idea what this even is and they might
think like oh now I have to let go of
this and I gotta give up this and I
can't have a girlfriend anymore and I
gotta change my life when in actuality
Allah expects progress not Perfection so
how would you describe Islam in a
nutshell yeah so I will answer that but
first I want to kind of touch on the
last point that was made um none of
these things will make you happy either
by the way you know watching a movie and
or being with random men or women or
whatever is not going to make you happy
or you'll feel good in the moment it
will not give you what is important
which is contentment people are looking
for happiness all the time you don't
want to look for happiness happiness
isn't in the moment feeling contentment
is a state of being in which you're
always happy contentment you're always
happy because you're content with what
you have you know a poor person who
thinks they should be rich is going to
be you know it's going to be very
depressed but a poor person who's is
like okay you know what this is what God
has given me I'm okay with it because
that is what he's written for me I'm
gonna do my best but if he doesn't will
for me to be rich that's fine obviously
the guy the second guy is going to be a
lot more content so now let me let me
elaborate on what Islam is Islam is the
most simple idea Islam has existed since
the beginning of human beings since Adam
and Eve says their earliest generation
you find that there is a belief in God
Islam is very simple it's believed the
one God worthy of worship and submit to
him alone do not worship any Partners or
Associates or anyone with him know that
there is no human being that's going to
intercede for you in this world and that
there's there's no statue or stolen or
industry or or being other than God that
you can worship in any way that's all it
says God created all of humanity with
one purpose which is to worship Him and
submit to him to enjoin good and to
forbid evil and know that your life will
come to an end and you will die you will
be buried six feet under the ground and
then afterwards you'll be risen on the
day of judgment and you will be held
accountable for everything you did or
any obligation that you had that you you
refuse to fulfill Islam is beautiful
because it holds people accountable it's
not just I believe in this I believe in
that it tells you the best way to live
life it tells you you have a
responsibility to your wife and your
kids you have a responsibility to the
brothers and sisters around you you have
a responsibility as a person to your
community if you're a leader you have a
responsibility to be fair and just with
those who are under you Islam is
something that Society actually needs
and that's why the Muslim Nation stood
up very strong for a thousand years and
they were the superpower for a thousand
years straight let me finish by saying
by the way Islam came at a tribalistic
period there were different tribes and a
lot of them hated each other
a lot of them hated each other when they
accepted Islam they all became Brothers
literally Allah says
he says indeed the Believers are
brothers so make peace with your
brothers the Muslims at the time even
though they hated each other before
Islam adopted this and literally became
Brothers they loved each other and Allah
the prophet peace upon him he says none
of you will truly believe until you love
for your brother what you love for
yourself this is what Islam teaches us
be a good person when worship God Alone
and before anyone has misconceptions
Allah tells us to believe in Moses in
Jesus in Noah in Abraham and all these
prophets and Messengers but that's the
thing they're they're prophets and
Messengers many religions not gonna name
any names no actually whatever I'll say
Christianity namely mainly taking Isa
Islam Jesus excuse me upon him as God
when we know that that can't be real bro
so once you essentially left this notion
of
dear Define a human being and and making
him God when we know he's just a human
being and essentially we understand
Jesus peace be upon him never died right
so he just got lifted and it was swapped
out he wasn't the one that was crucified
or anything like that and we believe in
the second coming too
how has your relationship with Jesus
changed from Christianity to Islam in
the way that you viewed Jesus peace be
upon him as a Christian versus now as a
Muslim
it fixes all the the complaints I had
internally when I was just going to
church when I was growing up uh
personally
I didn't like the fact that and no
disrespect to the Catholics watching I
didn't like the community the Holy
Communion where you go I don't know if
you understand but the priest has a bowl
of crackers literally and then he hands
it to you and he says this is the body
of Christ and then you take it and then
you put it and then you're symbolizing
that you're taking Jesus's sacrifice so
essentially
it's I don't want to be disrespectful
when I say this but essentially it
symbolized cannibalism because you're
eating his body his body is a symbol of
the cracker that's true and then you
drink the wine that's a symbol of his
blood this is Jesus blood and then you
sip it out of respect for for him and I
I like the fact that Islam it uh doesn't
draw Muhammad peace be bottom but you're
not supposed to ever visualize that
because we he was not alive in our time
there's no way that we would know what
he looked like especially uh Allah God
he's never drawn we have no idea what he
looks like or because there's no way
humans are too stupid we would never
we're not mentally capable of
understanding what God
conceptualize we can't conceptualize so
it's not supposed to in Christianity or
grow up when you have like God on a
cloud and it's like this guy with a
white dude on a beard he's like laying
in a cloud and he's like putting his
hand down like why I don't I I don't
like this is just what I was thinking
growing up like this doesn't make sense
to me and I and I all respect to Jesus I
believe that he was a prophet and he was
spreading the message of God but I don't
believe a man could also be God that
never makes sense that we are worshiping
a man that we are treating him as if he
is God and a man at the same time it's
that doesn't logic it never made sense
to me and how every single Church you go
in there's a different version of Jesus
all bloody and we we look at him and we
cry and we're always talking about all
the sacrifices he made he's the only
sinless person but
I don't I just never liked the fact that
we were worshiping a man I think the
only person that you should the only
being you should worship is Allah so it
did fix that problem that that never
clicked in my head and also the
the hierarchy and the chat's going crazy
right now
um let him bro
yeah I really don't want to I I mean
this is gonna get clipped or I'm gonna
get people upset but like for real if
you're gonna clip it up just make sure
that you put in the part where I'm
saying no disrespect to Christianity at
all this is just a personal uh feelings
I had as as a kid and why I never fully
resonated um with Christianity uh to
that level
and another big problem too is
to level up in scholarship in
Christianity in predominantly in the
church culture
pastors and and nuns it's almost like
you're married to the church at that
point that's what they say so because of
that they have to be celibate
now if God created a religion that's
from him and it's true why would you
have to be celibate would God not
understand are carnal desires as men and
women now I get it at the end of the day
we should curb these desires and there's
there's parameters of you know extremism
and immorality right but at the end of
the day what is this whole notion of be
celibate and then a byproduct of that is
all of these church church fathers and
figures being exposed and Priests being
exposed with what tens of thousands of
little boys that they're preying on do
you get what I mean so it's kind of like
creating one extreme is obviously going
to birth another extreme in Islam we're
not shy about sexuality or intimacy or
anything like that bro it's a matter of
fact that's what that's the thing bro we
got married young and marriage doesn't
it's not in the sense that the way that
a lot of people in the manosphere look
at it as oh you're just you're doing
this and you're dropping 500k on a ring
and you know a million on a wedding and
you're a simp and or you're whatever no
bro it's simply a union in the eyes of
Allah between a man and a woman so Allah
can give Baraka or blessings into the
couple and then they're basically
permissible to have intercourse with one
another because there's accountability
now you can't just hit it and quit it if
that makes sense and at the end of the
day it doesn't yield the generacy but
also doesn't yield these people that
have sexual deviance because they're
curbing their sexual desires something
that is not supposed to be curbed bro at
the end of the day if you can't even
have one wife bro like you want more
than half up to four if you can be fair
and just to the best of your ability but
there's no false Haya or false shyness
that let's put on the front that we're
all monks and you know to get to this
higher level of Enlightenment we gotta
act like we don't have sexual desires
bro
it's good to embrace it it's it's good
to instead of act like or try to
suppress it forever because it's going
to manifest itself in some way or
another like that is that that lust or
that those feelings are it's going to uh
come out in some way I got a one dollar
donation from from Ryan Dawson shout out
to him
he's a um
he's a I would say he's an atheist and I
visited him in Japan and he exposed a
lot of the truth about Zionism and about
he he's very educated on religions and
his question was uh how can you prove
that Quran was written by
Allah and not written by a man
yeah so you want to give a quick uh
clarification to Quran it's just the
word of God all right so but go in bro
yeah so I mean firstly I want to make a
distinction between writing and
authoring right
um men wrote it down but it was sent by
God that's what you believe and the way
to prove it per se is actually I think
very simple the Quran itself it gives a
challenge it says this is the book that
God has revealed right if you basically
have doubtites from God then produce
just one chapter like it produce a
chapter like the Quran and I know you
might be thinking oh that's probably
easy because you're reading the English
but when you when you read it in Arabic
and you can go to Every experts there's
videos that they made on it harms of
sources actually I think made a video on
it the shortest shortest chapter in the
Quran
is like I think 13 words
and it uses like over 20 rhetorical
devices this is something that Eminem
couldn't do when he when he was rapping
and the Quran was revealed kind of
piecemeal off the top so the prophet
peace upon him would come and say I got
revelation of God from God he would
recite it to the people and once he
recited that was it this is what all the
companions who spoke about it narrated
so you have many different reports
narrating it he would comment he would
just recite it and that's it describes
him would write it down and then they
would go on there and memorize and so on
and so forth so you have to make
something off the top of your head that
is I don't want to say poetic because
it's not a book of poetry but to
something that is rhythmic that has some
kind of Melody that could be recited
with that has many rhetorical devices
at the same time does not contradict
itself or very clear reality
um and on top of that that's just one
argument that God gives in the Quran as
humans we can derive more things for
example Allah promised that the Quran
would be preserved so if the Quran was
not preserved then Islam can't be true
look at the abundance of evidence that
we have to show the Quran has been
preserved
um there's actually a manuscript that
was from the time of the companions of
the Prophet so basically very close to
the time of the prophet and if you were
to read it even if it's ancient Arabic
you can read it you see that the the
words and the letters are exactly the
same
and this is the same book that Muslims
are memorizing today so all of that in
the last one I want to say and I think
one of the most powerful examples is the
prophecy or the the Prophecies of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him if
you want to know if you know Islam is
true
uh you can prove the prophet Muhammad is
the true prophet of God because what did
he come with the Quran Islam and vice
versa the Quran is true the prophet is a
true prophet of God when you look at
what he predicted it's insanely accurate
and some of them specify time play
circumstance for example he said
Barefoot Arab Bedouins you know poor
like sheep herding people would compete
in building tall buildings
where's the tallest building in the
world you were just there Dubai Dubai
this land you know 50 100 years ago was
a bare desert it was literally desert
and the prophet said 1400 years ago
peace upon him that there would come a
time before the day of judgment where
Barefoot Arab Bedouins are competing in
building tall buildings that's just one
example he predicted he also said that
there will come a time where people are
fornicating in the street like donkeys
literally he said that the fornicating
industry like donkeys and then he tied
this with the spread of a disease or
diseases that people have never seen
before STDs this is something that is
spread because of sexual promiscuity to
the point where people don't mind even
doing it out in the street
that's something else you predicted and
there's many more examples I've seen a
lot of the the predictions that it's
scary how accurate it was and how many
uh is it more accurate than the Simpsons
yeah we're in the end of days bro for
sure
yeah
what's your prediction going forward
because
the way I see it and um
the reason I have so many angry
Christians in my chat is I was attached
to this movement called America first
and I still believe in it that's uh it's
basically a Christian nationalist
movement to put America first it's based
off of um well I mean look Christianity
is rooted in in the west so it's like
Islam replacing the main religion in the
west is not very possible and the reason
I agree with that is because if it was
built on uh Christian values then that
should be the solution to all the
problems right now so I do believe in
America First and it started off with uh
with Trump in 2016. you basically this
Outsider that came in against the
political agenda against like all these
bonsole politicians as an outsider going
against the global agenda saying we need
to put America first we need to stop
putting money in all these pointless
Wars we need to focus on our own country
and so this this ideology was built
and
seeing it now it's it's very difficult
for that to really flourish if you see
where the powers are going and if you
see how many people are becoming
completely degenerate and lost in the
west so it's it's almost it's hard to
believe that a Christian nationalist
movement would ever work I I honestly
like logically if you look at the if you
look at what's happening if you see what
like what is happening to the church no
disrespect if you see like the drag
queens that are go that are coming in
there that the amount of like there was
just this video that's been going on
Twitter I don't know if you saw it of a
Satanist ripping apart the Bible like if
as a trans like it's it's
and she's fine like we all know that
that would not be allowed and it's like
that would never that would never stand
so just looking at the future
like what side or what side would you
would you want to be on
yeah so right now some people might say
they want to be in like on the liberal
side or the a-religious side because for
them it seems to be winning
but this is a big mistake because at the
end as Allah says in the Quran that when
truth comes false to advantages and
indeed falsehood is sure to vanish so we
know that eventually this stuff is going
to pass we already see the downfall of
the society America and Canada they've
gotten weaker
um you know economically they've gotten
weaker socially they've gotten weaker in
terms of the the people the individuals
and obviously a nation is built up of
the individual so if every individual is
weak the whole nation's weak it doesn't
matter what kind of Technology you have
uh the whole nation's dumb or if
everyone's dumb the whole nation's dumb
doesn't matter how how much AI you have
but regardless what we know islamically
is that the prophet peace be upon him he
said that Injustice would spread all
throughout the Earth that no matter
where you are in the earth there will be
Injustice is taking place maybe even
horrible injustices I think we live in
that time now we're very very close to
it and then he says there will come a
time afterwards where the Muslims regain
their power and the Muslims will be
dominant on the earth and he says he
gives us a very specific example to the
point where a female sheep herder a
woman who's out in in in the public
herding sheep you know not hurting them
physically but like you know h-e-r-d
like a sheep herder
she the only thing she has to worry
about is God you know she has to be
conscious of God and maybe a wolf might
eat her her sheep there's no man that's
going to steal her sheep from her
there's no man that's going to harm her
physically or harass her sexually or
anything like that that is how just the
world will be once the Muslims take over
again that's what we believe so if you
want to be on the winning side then
become a Muslim submit to God and even
if you don't live to see that time
you'll die a Muslim and God will reward
you but if you do live to see that time
then you can be a part of the solution
and not fight against you know the the
inevitable which is Islam
and I want to give a quick uh PSA to all
the people that are a little bit too
harsh and extreme not everyone is going
to leave falsehood and come into Islam
overnight just like brother sneaker was
saying so if somebody leaves
Christianity they might not leave
Christianity for Islam they might just
leave Christianity coming to a
realization that it's not true and it
might take five to ten years before they
accept Islam leaving one thing doesn't
automatically mean that they're gonna be
forced to accept the Sun the next day
and it's a process at the end of the day
so sometimes we we must have sympathy
and empathy for people that are leaving
falsehood because at least they left
something that's not true and now
they're closer to being on the correct
path to God it doesn't necessarily mean
they're going to be perfect Muslim
tomorrow
but why not yeah yeah I want to jump in
quickly and say uh I'm gonna go to the
bathroom quickly I'll be back inshallah
in a minute okay we can wrap it up I
have um
I have another guest that that's
supposed to be on them a little bit late
um this conversation was extremely
interesting um we have people right now
one more from Ryan Dawson he said which
areas are more violent Middle East with
God or Japan without God I would argue
that that Middle East is violent because
of all the different
ideologies and all the competing
um societies it's the Japan is a
homogenous place that's why there's less
violence but uh quickly before you end
it so I want to say thank you to the
three Muslims uh Angel fed and Rami for
for helping me on this um on this path
and also uh Tom Khan and Mohammed hijab
I learned from a lot of and also the um
yeah jewel of course or we we mentioned
it but who remember that one time we had
a Muslim scholar join a debate oh man
yeah that I I also shout out to Young
Don too for for trying to for trying to
guide me and he's he's a he's a really
good-hearted person and uh yeah yeah
it's all love but
yeah so so thank you
um I appreciate you guys coming on I
would like to have more conversations
and even privately if I could message
you and and learn more about the Quran
and like how I could be better as a new
Muslim I really want Israel to do the
really want to do the right thing with
this
inshallah and we gotta meet up soon bro
for an in-person podcast inshallah yeah
I think that would uh that'd be great to
see I really liked uh your Channel's
been doing great
all thanks is to God may Allah accept it
from us and we Allah accept it from you
we're very happy and proud of you uh
your brother and Islam now so may Allah
bless you mostly anything you need
inshallah will say in touch and like I
mentioned we'll send you the copy of the
Quran so you don't got to read The
Shakespearean stuff okay thank you so
much
uh what'd you guys think
a little more uh high IQ conversation
compared to yesterday
was brutal with uh those monkey
conversations I'd like to
I enjoyed that
I think it was a good song
w a lot of W's in the chat yeah that was
really good that was really
um a good conversation